colombian authorities are warning that
anti-government protests threaten to
prolong a devastating third wave of the
pandemic
on friday confirmed deaths from covet 19
past 80 000 and hospital awards are full
but the protesters are undeterred they
say little has been done about
another death toll that of demonstrators
shot by security forces
dw's johann ramirez is in kali where
people have been taken to the streets to
demand
answers
these demonstrators in cali are headed
for the pan-american highway
to blockade one of colombia's most
important trade routes
their protests have met fierce
resistance
including being shot at
organizers say the justice system has
shown no interest
in investigating the shooting
also nothing about our people who have
gone missing
or about the women raped by police
officials
the state doesn't listen it's a
dictatorship that's oppressing the
people
more and more
human rights activists have joined in
organizers see them as a way to increase
visibility
for their cause
[Music]
the people ask us to help so that the
international community contributes
we need the international community to
contribute so that life is respected in
this country
during this absolutely dignified
struggle for justice
that struggle has cost the lives of
almost 50 people
in recent weeks according to human
rights activists
in this cali neighborhood people offer
evidence of the violence they've faced
they claim that security forces shoot at
them with live ammunition
and point to these bullet holes as proof
this little hole was caused by these
things the police shoot at us
they insist that they shoot rubber
bullets but look at this
[Music]
what started as a rally against tax
reform
has turned into more than two weeks of
protests
it's threatening the political order
with calls for the president's
resignation
growing louder
you